You might wanna open your eyes,
because our ghost usually writes.
Oh.
Relax, we can take the bus back.
Great, is GW paying the fare?
Ha ha ha, don't worry!
We're all mad here.
I'm definitely getting mad.
I don't want to say it out loud
because then it might be real.
And I really don't want it
to be real.
I would say no way,
but then again,
we talk to book characters, so...
anything's possible.
It give me such great happiness
to see you again.
Right, well, now that's out
of the way.
Can we just tell her
that she's from a book?
No way, it's too weird!
Couldn't just give us a quiet
night off,
could you, Ghostwriter?
My grandma wants us to go up to
a wild tiger and... talk to him?
Not it.
I have a life outside of
finding missing book characters.
Good for you.
Well, this is the end.
At least I made my
bed this morning.
I didn't.
Well, GW. Left us a pretty
good cliffhanger.
We’re just, uh...
Yeah, I got nothing.
Hello.
What did you mean by that?
Nothing. I just meant hello
as in hello.
Well that didn't work.
No kidding, Sherlock.
Take Curtis's bed.
Where am I gonna sleep?
I don't know. The floor?
I just remembered that
I have a, um...
A trampoline lesson.
Trampoline lesson!
Make sure you fit
into the world of humans.
How am I doing?
Could be better.
Well played.
I know. I mean thanks.
This is gonna be like
finding a needle in a haystack.
Hey, thanks Ghostwriter.
There is one thing I
don't understand.
There's more than one thing
you can't understand, Joan.
You can't understand
German or French.
No.
Uh huh.
You think she's onto us?
Yeah, Chevon,
she knows we're
talking to fictional characters.
It's a little hard to believe.
I travel through time
on a transforming pirate ship.
I'm an expert in
hard to believe.
Just make sure you
don't like barricade yourselves
inside an elevator
or something.
That's rule number
one in horror movies.
This cat is very strange.
Me? Your hair hasn't
been combed in what,
your whole life?
Wow. The dogs look great.
Yeah, no thanks to you.
My parents will probably
ground him for the next year.
It's like jail for kids.
Sounds like fake science.
We’re talking to characters
from a book
and you're questioning
fake science?
I'll tell you one thing
I'm going to do.
Read more books.
What? I like books now.